yeah and look the bottom line is you
have a great quarterback or you don't
and there's that third category of team
that isn't quite sure whether or not
their quarterback is going to be a
franchise quarterback and they're giving
it more time before they pick one side
of the other and the Dolphins most
recently gave extra time to Ryan
Tannehill before they decided he's not
the guy now in New Orleans they know
Drew Brees is the guy the question is
who's the guy after Drew Brees moves on
and tastes some Hill is generating some
positive buzz he's not just a gimmick
he's not just a guy who's gonna come in
and throw the ball deep down the field
and Sean Payton had this to say about
Taysom Hill in comparing him Steve to
your good friend Chris to your good
friend Steve Young I said was going so
well until I blew it till your good
friend Chris Steve Young if you look
back at Steve's career people don't
remember the time before he came to the
NFL he you have a very athletic player I
think that advanced when he got to San
Francisco he always had great ability
with those legs so you're trying to
create visions for players and that's no
different than how you devaluate how we
see Teddy Bridgewater progressing and
what we think he can be that's the
business we're in so you take this and
we referred to Matthew Stafford as kind
of a lump of clay that's never been
formed into a real franchise quarterback
by coaching you take a guy like Taysom
Hill with those skills and you have Sean
Payton craft him into the best
decision-maker he can be and a guy who
can take advantage of the mismatches
that Payton can create through great
design of plays maybe Taysom Hill is the
next guy in New Orleans he gave us all
hope the other day in Los Angeles
against the Chargers I can say that it
was not just gimmick crap it wasn't just
oh I can throw the ball 50 yards and a
laser down the field and you know
hopefully it's on target no it was it
was kind of real quarterback play what
we saw and I think that's extremely
encouraging and and Sean Payton is right
you know Steve Young early on in his
49er career I mean they were like re
working with them on how to throw the
football I mean they really were and
taste some Hills been an athlete and he
has to learn how to play quarterback but
I think this is very intriguing I mean
do you think you know do you think
they'd make
Kim the backup quarterback there would
teddy bridgewater leave town would they
release him I mean it's just it's
interesting me it's not like teddy
bridgewater and I know he was under the
weather the other day has blown us away
with what he did at the end of last year
or what we've seen in the preseason to
this point and taste some he'll I come
away seeing him and I come away with my
jaw drop sometimes and blown away going
whoa I mean that was an unreal throw and
whoa there was a little touch on that
pass over the middle and then whoa look
at that run breaking tackles outrunning
people down the sideline I mean you know
the probe is kind of in the pudding
right now and I just wonder if Sean
Payton in company I'll have the guts to
make that type of move well look here's
the bottom line I don't think Teddy
Bridgewater is going anywhere I think
Sean Payton wants to continue to work
with him there is a very strong
connection between Teddy Bridgewater and
Bill Parcells and there's a strong
connection between Bill Parcells and
Sean Payton and remember Teddy
Bridgewater was talking about joining
the Dolphins before the the Saints got
Rhian volved and said we want you to
stay here they have a vision for Teddy
Bridgewater and regardless of how you
order the depth chart the bottom line is
all three quarterbacks are going to
address every Sunday for the Saints
you're going to have Brees you're gonna
have Bridgewater you're gonna have Hill
so you can keep Hill at number three but
just use him more often
what's Teddy Bridgewater gonna say hey
I'm the number two guy I should be going
into the game more so I think that then
he'll you know it gets very interesting
and I don't want to put the jinx on Drew
especially since I interview him in two
hours if he would get injured who would
be the guy that's really the question
yeah would it be Bridgewater would it be
Hill would it be both right and I agree
Shawn pay the perspective you probably
would use both guys and maybe equal
measure he might at first he certainly
might I mean you know Teddy
Bridgewater's of course more traditional
used to executing these type of offenses
to where he might feel more comfortable
from that standpoint throwing
Bridgewater out there taste some Hill
yes to to what we know and seen in the
NFL's been that gadget guy with an
occasional throw just to keep everybody
honest but it seems like he is evolving
along those lines and yeah it could be
one of those things where they throw
kind of both of them out there and maybe
a week or two go by and games where he
looks at and goes okay no you know I'm
gonna go with this guy now I've seen
enough
these two games could be something like
that but you're right - they're gonna
keep all three guys we know that because
Taysom Hill has a huge niche on on
special teams and things like that so
they need him in that and that in that
area as well
and and this is one of those feather in
the cap type players where Sean Payton
found him and developed him and in that
regard there there are some some rough
parallels back to Bill Parcells Sean
Payton and Tony Romo in Dallas because
Romo an undrafted guy that nobody really
knew all that much about and Bill
Parcells turned him into that franchise
quarterback remember when Sean Payton
got the job in New Orleans in 2006 one
of the first things he tried to do was
trade for Tony Romo before he'd become
the starter in Dallas and Parcells said
no way know how so I think there's some
pride that goes into saying I found this
guy and I made this guy and maybe he
will be the guy
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports